I want to talk about impressions and I
think a good place to start would be
first impressions because you see as I
walk up here today wearing this
incredibly dope outfit each of you
whether you realize it or not as made a
snap judgment about me based on my look
alone before any work inside my mouth
first impressions matter and research
shows that it takes one second to make
an impression on somebody and people
judge people in just one second and
unfortunately as I remove this outfit
and show a bit more of a reasonable
outfit for a presentation like this I'm
not going to have an opportunity to make
that first impression again people judge
you based on your look and potentially
the first words out of your mouth on a
number of personality traits and just
that one second the time it takes to say
hello people are determining whether or
not to think you're trustworthy
confident competent warm amicable and a
number of other traits that are going to
impact the manner in which they respond
to the rest of your presentation this is
a big deal if you enter your
presentation and people immediately
don't think that you're trustworthy then
your presentations going to fall flat so
what can you do to make sure that you do
have a good first impression on your
audience and get your presentation
kicked off in the right foot let's start
with some bad news you can't control
everything
if you're tall you're tall if you're
short you're sure if you have an
interesting sounding voice let's say a
high pitched or low pitch to harass me
well there's not much you can do about
that
you also can't really control the biases
that your crowd may already have they're
going to have certain biases already so
if you can't control these things does
that mean that you're at a loss or
something to do well not really because
what you can do is you can
overcompensate as an example let's say
that you're someone who's much shorter
in that circumstance you can make the
extra effort to make sure that you have
good posture that you stand straight and
that you strike a confident pose or if
you're somebody who say let's say has a
very low raspy voice that might shock
your crowd initially what you could
potentially do if the situation calls
for it is
call attention to your voice and
actually maybe make a joke about it and
make them feel more comfortable when
they hear you for the first time the
tricky is understanding where your crowd
may have biases and figuring out how you
can minimal minimize those biases by
doing something else now there are a
number of things that you can control
these include things like the way you
enter the room or the first words that
are out of your mouth or what you're
wearing or potentially the title of your
presentation if you do have a title
these are all things that are critically
important that your crowds going to see
from the get-go and you need to really
think about these things to figure out
what first impression you want to leave
with your audience there's really one
important thing you need to remember to
be able to figure out how to craft these
things and that is who is your audience
how do you want your audience to
perceive me do you want them to view you
as a peer or as a superior or something
in between and the answer to that
ultimately is going to determine the way
you should dress the way you should
speak and the first words on your slides
so if you know your audience and you
know what biases they may have you
structure the things you can control to
match that audience and you're trying to
overcompensate for the things that you
can't control you can make a good first
impression
now unfortunately at this point in time
you haven't actually said anything yet
so how do you make sure when your
audience leaves that room that you leave
them with a lasting impression what if I
told you that I have found the one thing
that can bring the role together the
ones the other thing that can bring
everybody in the world together the
world's a big place over seven billion
people and I've found the one thing that
can bring every continent every country
every person together over seven billion
people would you believe me it's pretty
surprising in fact I was surprised
myself cuz I can just confess one thing
to you I found this out when I was nine
years old now what do we think the
solution is do we think it's science
technology art music government
philanthropy do you have any idea of
what it might be any guesses love is
usually a good a good solution that
people often think of that's not what
I'm thinking of and that's not the
solution
that's a subcategory of this nation but
let me get right to the point
the solution soccer now you might be
asking yourself how a soccer gonna bring
the world together how is it the one
thing that can be the solution that
brings everyone together and that is a
valid question if it has to do so we're
not going to talk about that now we're
just gonna take a step back from the
story and we're gonna talk about what I
was trying to do with that story ideally
and hopefully with the effect that we
were intending to make a lasting
impression and what was I trying to do
tee's before you tell when you tease
before you tell reaches has shown that
there's a few things that can actually
help engage the audience and actually
engage learning so there was a study
done by UC Davis where they had people
go through a process of asking questions
and the questions that they were more
interested in and more curious about
actually led to better learning and then
better subsequent learning and the
reason that was important is because it
piqued their interest they wanted to
learn more it engaged them and they were
excited for what was to come
so how do you do this a few things that
I was trying to employ ask your audience
questions try to engage them tease them
with answers or tease them about
potential answers reveal and answer to
them and then ultimately dive into some
of the points you want to make well
unfortunately I haven't done it in two I
my soccers the solution that's one way
that you can continue to engage them and
then you can lead to further discussion
all in all these are things that are
really important to consider for
actually getting to your story but now
the big question becomes how do you
eventually go about telling that story
most effectively well you could stop by
showing something so we had a pitch just
now here's my pitch let's say I want to
sell you something I want to convince
you guys to change your bicycles from
one if a regular metal bike chain to a
carbon fiber belt drive system one ways
I could show on these slides the set of
specifications they hold it's a
high-strength carbon fiber belt who
lasts a lot longer
or I could highlight some of the
benefits that you never ever have to
grease and service your methyl bike
chain again saving you time and money
but another way is I could simply just
bring the bike here for you guys to see
for yourself there's nothing like having
the audience have an upfront and close
encounter with a product I could even
run the light demo I could let you guys
one of the audience members take it off
for a test drive and come back and talk
about how great that product gets kind
of like the earlier medical application
you could actually bring the app here
and let the audience members see for
themselves how good it is you might
think it's a high-risk maneuver but if
you have confidence you have to have
confidence you in front of the seller
now not all of us will have to be in a
rural area selling something on it make
a pitch go VC but upon graduation I'm
sure everyone here who have to convince
people using data so what if I told you
that a bag of movie popcorn a small one
used to contain 37 grams of saturated
fats that's almost twice the recommended
daily limit did I really have an impact
on you how about I told you that that
small bag of popcorn if you eat it is
technically healthier than having greasy
bacon and eggs for breakfast big mac and
fries for lunch
and topping off stick with all the fats
left in for dinner oh that's the
approach their nonprofit organization
did in the 1990s to which a media
campaign against movie food vendors who
are selling popcorn using cheap coconut
oil to cook the popcorn and because of
the media frenzy and the public outcry
those guys have to switch to a healthy
alternative so what I show you instead
of just displaying charts tables I
translated that information to something
concrete and tangible such they'll make
an impact on the audience well some of
you may still not be convinced like
three four days after the headlines
people forget about that information
right let's do a short experiment I'll
just give a couple of prompts you don't
have a shotgun cell but here goes so
like you do recall the first line of the
song hae Joo after you about five
seconds
now I'd like you to recall the
definition of the word truth I'm gonna
hesitate and think that for most of you
one was a lot simpler than the other
and researchers at the University of
Duke University attribute this to the
velcro theory of memory they found like
our brains very much like velcro has
thousands and thousands of discrete
pieces of information very disorganized
like the furry loops on the velcro until
they come in contact with a solid hook a
hook like that information I told you
about the popcorn how unhealthy it is so
the woman you have that you will make a
lasting impression and I hope I made
that simple enough for you
speaking of simplicity simplicity is the
key to making your message stick I'd
like to introduce a fruit it's called
the pomelo I could tell you all types of
information about this particular fruit
it's grown in Asia it's best in
subtropical climates it has lots and
lots of antioxidants but we often know
so much about a particular subject that
we're presenting on that we end up
sounding kind of like Wikipedia page
I've inundated you with all this
information about a particular fruit but
there's nothing actually concrete about
it another option is that I could say a
pomelo it's kind of like a big
grapefruit so whenever you're presenting
information think of these two different
options you could give a lot of details
and a lot of information or you could
have one simple analogy that's really
evocative so just think about these two
choices if you're maybe doing a work
presentation where you happen to know a
lot about particular topic I'd also like
to introduce a secret of Hollywood
executives it's called the high-concept
pitch so when it comes time to introduce
a new
movie or a new particular show that you
might want to pitch take this example
speed again doesn't doesn't say very
much or you try explaining it it's gonna
have counter reason it's gonna be
amazing or I could say it's like diehard
but on a bus and the reason this works
is because it's your drawing on
something that people know already and
it's going to invoke a lot of specific
imagery and we hear this a lot in
Silicon Valley for example there could
be the uber of X the uber uber of
dog-sitting
and this is often overused but to the
extent that you can find some other
example that people can draw upon
already it's when you make it much
easier for that message to be simple and
for that message to stop you and last
I'd like to talk about the power of
Proverbs for example one of my favorite
proverbs or a famous saying is asked not
what your country can do for you but
what you can do for your country it's
also a JFK JFK quote like Killians
earlier and the reason that these
proverbs work is because they're simple
it's just one line and they're very
profound so if you have a presentation
think if you can just distill it to one
line to one saying that's going to stick
with people what might that be and for
this particular section I'll just use
the US Navy saying which is keep it
simple stupid
u.s. Navy design principle think of how
do you make everything as approachable
as possible so now we've given you the
tools to make both a great first
impression and also to make your message
last
[Music]